[Music]
slapped ah we're gonna watch from salaat
ham today these children were scared by
real ghosts
we watched the scary tick-tock one from
him last week
and that delivered sure this one will
deliver let's just swing on an action
now children funny as this videos been
around for a long time many people have
attempted to explain it some think it
could be a well-planned hoax and whether
many believe that these girls really did
see it goes so it's so physical
yeah the girl on the left is it creaking
and turns around however the other girl
is too engrossed in her song to notice
then suddenly a bottle of water is
pushed off the desk just before the door
violently slams shut both girls who
visibly shaken as they scream for their
dad featured two Australian girls in
their video also flies across the room
as the door slams shut behind them maybe
the ghost was killed by a song every
time a genuinely loved it if the parents
of video uploaded to Ellie X's YouTube
channel in February 2015 a piece to show
a young child being pushed over by some
sort of unseen force while some noted
that the child might have simply got
overexcited and slipped
others believe that they really were
pushed over by something's wrong if you
slow the footage down you can see that
the child actually appears to be shoved
in the chest and that seems to be what
causes them to toe oh it's Justin Rafi
what's this child pushed over by a ghost
or is it more likely that they simply
lost balance and fell let me know what
you think in the comment section below
I mean they could yeah it's like it
could Lodge their own or by the
mysterious things they see sometimes
it's those around them that get spooked
by the child's ability to communicate
with something that isn't there
even this eerie clip uploaded to us CI
okay's YouTube channel in March 2013 a
young boy attempts to convince his
mother that he can see something that
she can't when she asked him who he's
trying to find he points into the other
room and says it goes while it's ugly
what happens next the way in which the
boy speaks in the clip seemed so
matter-of-fact it's almost as if he's
certain there really something that he's
mother can't see the next room there are
many videos on YouTube that appeared
with captured children communicating
with ghosts hmm in this video posted to
YouTube by PS Scotty three two one in
January 2013 a young girl could be seen
sitting at the dinner table
her brother mentions in the description
and he was recording her as he left the
room to see if she would touch his food
sure enough she does however it's what
happens just before that there were true
chills
the girl appears to communicate there
someone by saying that's Billy's dinner
at first it seems as though she's just
playing around and the girl really does
seem to be able to communicate with the
ghost could it actually be possible that
this girl is friends with a poltergeist
or is there another explanation for the
falx mysterious movement why are you go
so so maybe it's hard to move material
matter
Landru the child seemed crying the
bottom right corner of the image refused
to take part in a picture a small child
when she was reviewing the photo
sometime later she was shocked finally
she understood what the little girl was
talking about what between the legs how
fascinating how fascinating you see the
young girls reaction tends to indicate
that she could really see the ghostly
child at the time looks like a movie
poster another example of a child's
ability to send something that week on
it certainly seems as though that could
be the case I need to review all my
photos yeah you probably can't like tons
it was horrifying when they saw the
black figure standing behind the two
children some believe it could be a
shadow person others think it might be
some sort of dark spirit that is somehow
attached itself to the children looking
at the photo really do
themselves they're only visible feature
as their eyes that you really peer out
from the darkness
well let's unclear what actually
happened after this photo was taken
if the mysterious finger was still
standing there when the children turned
around they would have surely received a
terrible fright yeah of course no that's
her friend who all would get to that
number one spot and take a look at what
has got to be one of the most unsettling
goes clips on YouTube remember to hit
that subscribe button and tickle the
bell icon that way you mean that in
October 2012
angel rulers uploaded this terrifying
clip to YouTube it shows two young
children as they seed-eating in a small
table one of the girls points to the
darkened room in front of them insist
that she can see something
she's clearly troubled by whatever it is
and keeps insisting that something's
they're afraid opana sister finds the
whole thing rather amusing could be a
pity to spook her further even the woman
filming tries to reassure the girl that
there's nothing there despite this she
becomes increasingly unsettled is the
clip goes on the girl eventually is
driven to tease and runs to the woman's
side while the video is unsettling up
until this point it's what happens next
that will surely give you chills
the girl who's still sitting at the
table decides to take another look in
the darkened room suddenly she lets out
a blood-curdling scream and she runs
towards the woman badly could there be a
ghost lurking in the darkness or is it
more likely to with being a spooky
shadow that sent them running maybe
there was like on this one really a big
spider
Floyd that's upset you don't want to see
what ghosts caught on camera then check
out that video on the top there
otherwise it's a creepy play this day
you can be done for hours now in the
comment section below let us know which
one of these clips kid you the most and
that's it for me I'll see you all next
time the first one to real not another
really well done video bye slapped ham
for sure that first one though I have to
believe that's fake it's just so like
it's sir present it's like it appears
out of the corner
it looks so tangible yeah yeah exactly
it looks like a person wearing a costume
yeah and then later on when they're
looking through the windows it looks
just like a shadow or an apparition and
then there's a different appearance to
it at the very least does make you
wonder I mean it's certainly really
creepy but I feel like it's too easy
I'll say this out of all the clips
especially in this video but even just
across all the spooky clips we've seen
in terms of one that could easily be
faked but also is pretty convincing I'll
give a critic the way that little girl
pops out the way they run into the next
room she's already at the top of the
stairs it's well timed enough that I was
sitting there going yeah and yeah that
one chilled me pretty good the second
one I thought was a little bit more
debatable yes I mean not to slight the
young children's performance already I
mean I think the first one is the
creepiest yet the one I also believed to
be the fakest simultaneously doing both
thing is is the more realistic it looks
on camera the less real and probably is
and the faker it looks like ever
probably the more reason you can't win
with audiences you can't that's either
that's the same way with Gauri yeah I
mean the second one looks very timed
it's like too generic for me and the
water bottle looks that looks fake like
when you slow it down especially it
looks like some post-editing effective
it just goes like this and then just
like fades out of frame I don't know it
doesn't fly across room doesn't fall
down really slow it down it has this
effect where it looks like you could see
the water bottle just disappear yeah
disappear mid frame yeah yeah and this
is also one of those ones that is framed
in such a way where it looks like it
wants you to not focus on but notice the
water bottle and the door which are
about to become the most you know active
ants of the video the kid the kid the
kid tripped I know other the kid tripped
directly it's easy to lose a balance
maybe he the kid did this first and then
lost balance yeah I mean I think it's
one of those that's timed well enough to
if you want to look at it that way and
go the kick if the kid got pushed I
think the thing is the the reaction
would have been different when they hit
the ground yeah I think there would have
been some kind of dismay or something
rather than just like whoops we're
having fun but I will say when you do
especially slow it down like it does
look like the kids just standing there
and then falls over so yeah
I want to say the ones that might be the
the creepiest in the form of
believability like the first one is the
creepiest to me but I don't buy it the
ones that creeped me out the most that I
feel like could potentially be real are
the ones where the two kids yeah the one
who's talking to like there's a ghost
down the hall and the one when the
brother leaves a room and then the
fourth moves especially the one with the
little girl talking to the ghost he's
played yeah that just seems way too real
yeah her performance if it is a
performance it's very believable very
sincere good actress she has a good
career I'd have her rather those clips
play into two different things one is
that you show us the build up the
suspense rather than the actual thing
it's gonna be scarier and biggie I do
think that there is something to
idea the children experience a little
differently and maybe speak a little bit
more genuinely or without that layer of
rationality that we all impose on
ourselves when we get older so there is
something a little bit more kind of
convincing about this kid who's just
like there's some min there and and and
it's talking to me and it's kind of
weird and especially when the kids not
even freaking out about it but he does
look concerned or even this little girl
is just like looking out for her dinner
or whatever things like that yeah those
little human nuances to make you wonder
now here's where I think it could be
fake though with a little girl here's
what's getting to me the root beer can
is blocked as if they're trying to avoid
some type of copyright issue main thing
that my mind is focused on of here's
what I think could be faked she kind of
holds it to frame but you never see the
logo you never see the logo full you see
one side and the other side you know
split apart so bless Ghost ahh both
bless you and then the brother could
have also just you know like walked
around the camera yeah I've just
festering or something and pulled the
fork the one with the photo with all the
girls I know all those girls by the way
first off we got his comment on the
photo like just the photo itself this is
not a great photo
look at the ends of this photo you got
one girl who looks like drunk and
hungover doesn't want to be in the photo
of her she's literally been pulled off
yeah and on the other side you got this
crying child like why did you take this
photo this is not a good photo you know
when people are so Jesus in my soup this
is not that that's a pretty clear cut
when I said movie poster it does feel
akin to when they do some type of
Exorcist film and then they have like
some type of graphic novel aesthetic to
the shadowy look yeah yeah yeah it's
made to look like oh here's a bunch of
different people in a normal state but
awesomes off about it yeah when you see
it you'll [ __ ] bricks that looks like a
pretty real shadowy figure and I'm more
likely to believe you can
sure a ghost in some type of flash
photography format yeah movies have
convinced me of this yeah well and I
mean the grain to like even if it is
editing the grain feels at least like it
may have a little authenticity between
their legs the thing that makes me
skeptical is the height cuz at least as
this image is cropped in the video I
don't know if there's any more of it but
it looks like the kid has to be like
kinda crouching his face between their
shins or maybe they're just taller than
they look what's great about the photo
though is that this photo is pretty wide
like you got a lot of negative space
everywhere around them yeah like what
are they trying to go this is just a
terrible photo why is not wise there's
so much space what if I'm here to talk
about the photography skills here well
so my point though with it is there's so
much negative space it feels natural
like there could be a ghost there
because of the fact that if you compare
it to the second video that we saw here
where everything is just perfectly in
frame to capture this go doesn't look
composed yeah composed in a way too so
that way people will focus on the ghost
like you had to point that out to me in
order for me to see it yeah you know and
that's the thing that could lend its up
with some believability it looks like
it's super normal super average yeah
yeah if anything I mean the child crying
maybe looks a little suspect and just
like the way the kind of grain deviates
but yeah I'll give it to him and the
shadow person appears behind children
it's a really creepy photo but I gotta
chalk it up to it being fake because of
the fact that it's just some random
photo yeah now there's no video footage
to sorta do am i there's no story to it
I mean it makes for the best thumbnail
yeah it's freaky like in terms of just
striking images this is maybe my
favorite of this video just because the
second I saw it I was freaked out you
know but yeah it is the kind of thing
where especially in just a photo I'm
like yeah there are a million ways
doctor this and good job you know this
should go on the something awful for him
and become a new Slender Man
it feels fake because the shadow is so
defined yeah this could be some type of
Jay horror character but in terms of a
shadow it just doesn't quite work cuz it
feels like Photoshop shadow like that
you put a human in shadow for you just
been a regular photo and that's the mom
behind him and someone took the photo at
the mob and made a shadow out of her
yeah yeah and the problem is most of us
don't have you know a first-hand
confirmation of what a shadow person
ought to look like in a regular
environment so there's also that I think
like reverse uncanny valley where I have
no visual reference for it in my real
life and so it just kind of looks like a
fantasy still but mincing fantasy at
that yeah I mean like I don't hope any
of these are real but if any of them I
hoped was real was that I really admire
the top one that he has listed here
because it's so simple it could be
absolutely fake this could be some stage
dating from the parents and kids
involved but the feather you don't see
anything and it's all slowly bent off of
the timing and the reactions of one girl
getting freaked out and then later on
the other girl getting freaked out by
whatever is in that area I think that's
really well staged if it is staged I
mean it could be real they couldn't saw
something maybe but I appreciate the
creepiness to it because it's solely
based off of time if they both got
scared at the same time but could have
felt very staged yeah no I had the one
girl like taunting her and then to turn
around and be like oh [ __ ] yeah you know
there's something authentic about just
the way the behavior plays in that clip
and I feel like that and the one with
the little blonde boy or the two that I
felt like could be real or authentic or
or something's going on yeah I got the
least sense that someone's trying to you
know pull one over and get me to school
yeah you know the way those two little
girls reacted just looked very natural
to me all right guys well which one of
these stood up to you the most make sure
to subscribe is slapped him as soon as
you can because a slap tab what he eats
out of the can-spam
wants to talk to is slapped ham fanbase
make a case for the ghost case and erase
all the thoughts that you might have
misplaced in okay we're done
click on notification bell hope you feel
well last but not least Lake Eric
Horstman Eric my dude what to say you
contribute way too much on our live
streams and don't stop that ever in fact
it's something worst case something were
to happen to you if you were to get
abducted by a ghost just find some way
where you could talk to your accountant
so he can keep contributing to our live
stream oh yeah appreciate that I would
love if Eric was our like ghost that
would haunt the studio because thank you
could be secondly they want a sincere
note I know things have been
exceptionally rough for you with the
hospital visit you had to go to recently
and I don't want to get too personal
over certain things that you were
telling me about that happen while you
were there I do want to say though that
I encourage you to get the treatment
that they were heavily suggesting to you
I think you would greatly benefit from
it and honestly the treatment that are
advising I think it would actually
really enjoy it I just want the best for
you buddy I really do like you've been
amazing to us in every possible way and
we make a lot of sarcastic comments
directed at you I still want to let you
know I really love you and I really want
you to take care of yourself and be the
best person possible you can be you have
a very giving generous heart and you're
very empathetic now it's time to take
care of your inner soul just a little
bit more please go out there and take
care of yourself dude worst case if you
don't talk to your accountant and see if
you can set up that livestream either
way there's there's an option we love
you and take good care of yourself see
you buddy